okay
so we're going to talk about piaget
today
and as i believe i mentioned to you
before
piaget was
perhaps the 20 20th century's foremost
developmental psychologist he didn't
really regard himself as a psychologist
however
in fact a lot of the people who've been
great psychologists have come in from
outside the field it's often engineers
for example engineers have helped us
establish most of our statistics
anyways piaget i suppose would have
regarded himself more as a biologist he
called it called himself a genetic
epistemologist
and by genetic he didn't mean the genes
that organize your
cells and
spin you up out of nothing he meant
beginnings
as in genesis and and then an
epistemologist was someone who was
interested in how structures of
knowledge
emerge
and how they're constituted so he
actually thought of himself as a
biological philosopher
now
you know one of the things that's kind
of sad about learning about
great theories is that you hardly ever
learn about how peculiar the people who
formulate them are because generally
they're extraordinarily interesting
people you know that that in some ways
that often they get sanitized in some
way once they've become respectable and
that's really quite unfortunate
piaget
was really a genius um he was offered
a position at a large museum and and i
remember i remember correctly it was
perhaps it wasn't director but it was a
position of approximately that stature
he was offered that when he was 10 years
old
he'd written a paper on mollusk behavior
which was published
and his parents told the museum people
that he of course they didn't know he
was 10
you know that he probably wasn't up for
the job at that time so but that gives
you some example some idea about the
magnitude of his intellect and piaget
wrote a lot
and you know usually what you hear about
if you study piaget in north america if
you hear about piaget you hear about his
stages of development
sensory motor etc and uh
that really wasn't what piaget was all
that interested in
there was something about the idea of
countable stages that seemed to appeal
to
north american developmental
psychologists but piaget didn't really
regard that necessarily as either the
central or the most important part of
his theoretical edifice
and you know part of what piaget has
been criticized for in recent years is
that the stages don't necessarily occur
either as he described or in the order
that he described but
in some ways he wouldn't have found that
particularly distressing because
it was more of an attempt to explain how
the personality
emerged out of nothing in some ways
because in some ways you kind of emerge
out of nothing you know and it's not
that easy to figure out
for piaget in some ways you sort of
booted up although he wouldn't have used
that metaphor obviously having existed
in the time before that was a commonly
known phenomena
so
he also was concerned about
high-level metaphysical problems and so
one of the things that really
motivated piaget
was
the contradiction between science and
religion that was very painful for him
and one of the things that he had set
out to do as a young man
was to
bridge the gap between science and
religion and in some ways you might
think about that
in relationship to the sorts of things
we talked about last class is that
he was attempting to bridge the gap
between a description of the world and a
prescriptive
description of the world which means
what the world is and how the world
should be or what the world is and how
you should act
and
i think that's the most straightforward
way of thinking about the division
between religion and science because you
need to know how to act you can think
about it as a division between morality
and science or you can think about it as
a division between behavioral wisdom and
science which i think is even a better
way of thinking about it because it it
takes the specifically
religious element out of it
so
but anyways piaget
wanted to devote his life to
solving that problem and i would say
that's what he did
he also identified an interesting stage
that you also hear very little about but
seems to be to be something worthy of
note and also worthy of consideration
he thought that many people
in their late adolescence went through a
messianic stage
and what he meant by that was that when
late adolescents or young adults were
trying to orient themselves in the world
they were trying to figure out how they
might plot their path forward in life so
that they actually made a difference you
know so they started to become concerned
about the state of the world and about
their role in determining that state and
and getting
interested in and perhaps involved in
large-scale political or social
movements and he was the only
psychologist that i've ever seen who
actually identified that as a stage but
it's worth thinking about you know
because it certainly is the case that
many young people do
pass through a stage that's something
like that and
it's interesting to speculate on it as a
you know standard part of human
development now i think it's probably
more characteristic of people with
certain personality types so i suspect
if you're more extroverted and you're
more open um particularly more open
which is the creativity dimension in the
big five that you're more likely to be
politically
and socially
compelled you know so we know for
example that openness is a very good
predictor of things like political
liberalism and uh you know certainly a
lot of the
millennial movements and the religious
like movements that you see on campus
that have what would arguably now be a
political base seem to be associated
with high openness so maybe that stage
doesn't occur in everyone's life but it
certainly seems to occur in many
people's lives okay so
now
you might ask yourself well what was
piaget up to and well he wanted to
figure out a lot of things and he was
interested in very very fundamental
issues so for example
his theories dealt with things like
number and space you probably can't see
that very well it doesn't matter i'll
tell you what it says time and speed
permanent objects how did how did a
person develop the notion of what
constituted a permanent object um how do
you know when one thing is the same when
it changes into something different so
for example if you pour one bit of
liquid from one container into another
how do you know that the amount of
liquid is the same
how do children develop their ideas of
chance and causality how do they develop
their
concerns about morality and their moral
knowledge what what what are they doing
when they're playing
and i think actually piaget's most
fundamental contribution as far as i'm
concerned came in his studies and
analysis of play and also to some degree
his his analysis of dreams and he also
spent a lot of time giving serious
consideration to the role that imitation
played in in the scaffolding of the
human personality and so
um
some of the
so
now piaget believed that
well i think this is the easiest way to
talk about it actually we'll use this
little diagram here so
i'll
shut this light off
here
it took me a long time to construct this
diagram so not because it's all that
technically difficult but it took a
while to think it up so i want to give
you a little bit of a
background to it so imagine that
one of the things that distinguishes a
human being from a computational device
say or at least the standard sort of
computational device is that our primary
cognitive problem is how to perceive the
world so that we can act in it so that
we can get what we need to have or want
okay so all three of those things are
roughly of equivalent importance right
you have to be able to perceive
and you have to be able to act because
you can't act then you can't get what
you need and if you can't get what you
need then of course there isn't and you
and so
we're trying to always solve those
problems simultaneously and we're also
trying to do it in a way that's
sustainable
now
what that means in part is that the
knowledge structures of human beings
are
organized or or or they're organized
along those three dimensions and those
three dimensions also constitute the
problem space in some sense that has to
be addressed for a solution to be useful
so
not only do you have to be able to
perceive in some accurate manner but the
accuracy is determined in part on
in terms of whether or not the way that
you're perceiving helps you pursue
something that you want to pursue and
then the utility of wanting to pursue
something is dependent to some degree on
the relationship between the utility of
that and the things that you need to
continue to survive
now
some psychologists have addressed that
by thinking about such things as
fundamental drives
you know and that was mostly a
behavioral idea in some ways and the
drive might be
hunger
and and the idea of a drive would be huh
that hunger is a motivator that helps
you put together strings of motor
behaviors that are sort of run out in
automatic sequence so that you can
you can get the end that you want and
continue on perhaps to fulfill another
drive
but the idea of drive is a little bit
on the oversimplified side although it
has its place i think that you can
conceptualize the relationship between
all of these by thinking in the
following manner so
imagine first of all that people are
after something generally speaking
now
if you look at us you can kind of tell
that we're the sorts of creatures that
are after things and the way that you
can tell that is first of all that we
can move
and and do so frequently so we're always
on a voyage of some sort or a journey of
some sort from point one to point two or
from point a to point b
i would say as well that that's also the
um
hallmark of a simple story if you're
telling someone a story generally what
you do is you tell them about a time
that you were somewhere and then you did
some things and you went somewhere else
it's a very very simple story
now the advantage of thinking about it
as a
story
is that
it helps you understand that the entire
cognitive structure
can't be reduced to necessarily anything
that's
for example that's drive drive-like you
have to think about it as more
personality-like
and so you want something
you orient yourself towards it now the
way you do that generally speaking is
with your sensory and your conceptual
systems right so for example if you want
to walk towards the door then you turn
your head and you make yourself a mortal
of the door and that model has to
um
be bounded by its relevance to your
actions so you know the things that are
going to be relevant to you about the
door for example might be whether or not
it's tall enough for you to walk through
or whether or not the doors open or
closed so that you can
as you're walking towards it you can
organize your body so that you can
interact with the object as you see fit
now
you pick your goals and also for all
sorts of different reasons and some of
those reasons are more fundamental than
others so for example fundamental by
fundamental i would mean
likely what i mean by fundamental is
something like evolutionarily ancient
you know so the the older the necessity
or the older the system that's evolved
to
allow you to pursue the necessity the
more fundamental it is and there's
there's ways of identifying what
constitutes the fundamental elements of
goal seeking behavior and you can do
that in part by comparing yourself to
other animals you know and so mammals
for example
all seem to gen to experience something
that you might regard as anger or at
least defensive aggression they're all
hungry you know they all have the the
they all act as if they're they're
they're uh
they highly value sexual behavior and so
forth and so those you can't really
think of those things as specifically
human they're lower level than that now
so
at a fundamental level you have
biological systems that are
setting forth what might constitute a
goal and you can think about that you
can think that what the system is doing
is setting the goal or you can think
that the system is driving behavior but
a better way of thinking about it is
that
the
fundamental motivation motivational
system sets up
framework that's like a personality that
then acts in the world and so this
personality has something in mind that
it wants
it has a collection of perceptions that
organize itself around that thing that
it wants and then it has a plan or
associated motor behaviors that it can
lay out in the world that will take it
from the point where it is to the point
that it wants to be
okay now so once you know that
then you can start to think about these
plans
or these goals or these stories or these
frameworks i think those are all you can
even think about them as games in some
ways you can think about them at
different levels of complexity
now what piaget was trying to do in part
was to describe how a
framework of this sort or a sub
a sub element of personality might
develop itself in complexity over time
so
the the diagram i have here before you
shows these little oval like
figures and in the bottom left hand
corner
there's a box that says what is and in
the top right hand corner there's a box
that says what should be and then
there's some arrows showing a planned
sequence of behavior and the idea is
that you have a sense of where you are
and you have a sense of where you're
going and that constitutes the framework
within which you're looking at the world
and then within that framework there's
different things that you can do with
your body in order to advance from the
first point to the second point now
it's it's important to understand that
this sort of thing is grounded in
behavior and not in conception because
it helps you also understand the nature
of these
fundamental elements of personality the
fundamental elements of personality are
not descriptions of the world they're
tools for acting in the world including
the associated behaviors now whether
they're behavioral or conceptual to some
degree depends on their level of
abstraction
so so here's how to think about that so
imagine that you say that someone's a
good person
and you might say well that's a
description of them
and
that and when you think about
description you tend to think about
description the way that you would
describe an object in the world like a
scientific description but when you talk
about someone as a good person you're
actually not describing them as an
object in the world you wouldn't even
describe yourself as an object out in
the world that way what you're doing is
using a shorthand to represent
a higher the hierarchical arrangement of
their personality and you can get away
with it because
when you say good person to someone they
already have an understanding of good
person and they know what that hierarchy
is and so you don't have to explain the
whole thing to them and you can
understand each other without even
necessarily knowing exactly the details
of what you're talking about but i'm
going to tell you now what i think you
mean when you say that sort of thing so
imagine that
a good person is a description at the
very at the top end of a hierarchy okay
because good the good is a very high
level
philosophical abstraction it's a high
level value be good
okay so what does that mean if you
decompose it well we'll do it in a
relatively straightforward manner one
that isn't really
it's more observational than
philosophical so let's say you take
you take someone who's a
40 year old mother for the sake of
argument and who will say she also has a
job so
if she's a good person and she's a
mother you might think that's one sub
element of her personality if she's a
good person is being a good parent
right and i think you put person above
parent in the hierarchy because to be a
good person
you can be a good parent without being a
good person but it's hard to see how you
could be a good person without being a
good parent so and maybe if you're a
good person you're more than a good
parent you know you're probably a good
partner and maybe you're good at your
job and like there are there are large
domains of activity
that you're good at or good in and if
you sum your behavior across that or
average your behavior across that or
something like that then you end up
reasonably being described as a good
person maybe you're a good friend as
well and so good person has levels of
hierarchy underneath it and we're and
then each of those things that have
levels of hierarchy each of those
entities at the level of hierarchy right
underneath good person can also be
decomposed so we're going to decompose
them and we're going to see what happens
because partly what happens is if you
decompose them you get right to the
bottom it's not an infinite
decomposition
and so i also think this is one way that
you can think about the relationship
between the mind and the body
because the relationship between the
mind and the body is a very tricky thing
because the mind seems to be made of
stuff that's other than the body and i
think there's some truth to that partly
because we don't really understand
consciousness but there are
but that's a complex problem and i think
you can get a fair ways in addressing
the mind body problem without having to
drag in the problem of consciousness so
okay so we could say well good person
sub element of that is good parent then
you might think well what is it that you
need to be doing to be a good parent
and we might say well
um you have to have a good job maybe
that's one up in the hierarchy but
whatever you have to have a good job
because otherwise you can't provide for
your children
and you have to be able to to care for
the children you might say well
someone's good at caring for children
and then you might ask them well what
does it mean to be good at caring for
children and then you have to sort of
think of the
sub elements that would go into caring
for children and so one of them here is
uh you have to know how to cook a meal
or complete a meal and then you also
have to know how to play with the baby
so we could concentrate on playing with
the baby and so what do you do when
you're playing with the baby you might
play peek-a-boo you might tickle the
baby and you might clean the baby okay
now you start thinking well
obviously once you're starting to get
down to that level of detail so that's a
high-resolution model right you're
you're starting to move from a low
resolution model good person to a high
resolution model which are what are
precisely the multitude of elements that
make up being a good person well if
you're playing peek-a-boo with a baby
for example all of a sudden you're doing
something that's not exactly conceptual
being a good person is conceptual but
playing peek-a-boo isn't conceptual and
the reason it's not conceptual is
because you actually have to move your
hands to do it
so if you get to a high enough level of
resolution in the description of a
personality what you start describing
are patterns of behavior now they have
associated you know they have an
associated motivational framework and a
viewpoint that goes along with them so
that i would say well even while you're
playing peek-a-boo with the baby that
the element of you that's playing
peek-a-boo is best described as a
sub-personality it's a playful
sub-personality and then it's the
sub-personality that specifically knows
how and is motivated to play peek-a-boo
but what it's composed of is no longer a
sub-personality it's starting to be
composed of actual movements
so and then underneath that if you go to
higher resolution like okay what's the
movement composed of well obviously you
start to have to talk about musculature
and then if you go below that it's
molecular movements and so on but but
once you're down below voluntary
movement there's really no you there
anymore right you sort of fade into
unconsciousness because you know how to
go like this
but you don't exactly know how to move
the specific muscles that enable you to
go like that or even if you do you don't
know how to twitch the muscle fibers or
something like that right there's some
le you don't know how to operate the
cells
there's some level of resolution
underneath voluntary motor control that
that basically runs on automatic and to
some degree you're capable of
like steering it but you're not really
capable of
you're certainly not capable of being
conscious of it
so the the abstract moral conception
which is also a description good person
hits the world at the level of motor
output
now and a lot of like even your sensory
movement a lot of that's motor output
right because a lot of what you're doing
with your eyes is moving them so all
right now what does that have to do with
piaget well one of the ways of
understanding piaget is that he built
he was really interested in
understanding how that entire system
came to be
and his theory is a bottom-up theory
he says okay yeah this is this this is
he hasn't said this but it's a very
useful way of thinking about it
because piaget believed that you started
with small elements of what he called
reflexive behavior and then you learn to
chain them together in increasingly
complex structures and then you chain
those complex structures into more and
more complex structures and so on and so
forth until you built up the entire
hierarchy but you tended to start from
the bottom so piaget was particularly
interested in
what the minimum conditions were
for something to emerge into the world
so that it could build itself out of
nothing
and that's really what he was interested
in when he was starting to talk about
infant development and so piaget's
hypothesis was something like this
um well chill babies are born very very
immature you might even say that they're
born premature so
um
a human baby if you took a mammal of red
about human size and you said well
what's its average gestation period
across the animal kingdom you'd find out
that for an animal of our size we should
have a gestation period a pregnancy
period of two years
so we don't we have a gestation period
of nine months and so you might ask well
why is that
and the answer is
complicated obviously but here's some of
the reasons as far as people can tell
um we have big heads
and they've really been expanding
rapidly over particularly over the last
two million years but let's say since we
split off from chimps that's about six
million years we have very very large
heads and you know if you look at a baby
a baby's head is pretty damn
disproportionately large compared to its
body like that a baby's like a third
head and so even when the baby's little
nine months old well nine months after
conception
and maybe a year and three months before
it's supposed to be born its head is
already extremely big now you think well
what's the problem with that and the
problem with that is well the bigger
your head is the harder it is to be born
and you might say well why haven't the
pelvic areas of human beings adjusted
females in particular adjusted so that
they could handle the
birth with a larger head and the answer
to that is well they have to some degree
which is why women have wider hips than
men do but the problem is
evolution is a conservative business and
it can only in some sense tinker with
what it's already got and so if you look
at
the basic
bought your basic body plan your basic
body plan at most in its most
fundamental levels was established some
some tens of millions or even hundreds
of millions of years ago and then the
basic mammalian body plan was
established say 60 million years ago and
so if you go i went to the smithsonian
once and they have a skeleton museum at
the smithsonian it's sort of like a zoo
for for skeletons and it's really
interesting place to go because
you can see much more how alike mammals
are when you see their skeletons so for
example if you see a bat skeleton it
looks just like a human skeleton except
the fingers are really really long but
it's the rest of it's like yeah that's
basically the same skeleton as a human
being it's just that the pieces have
blown up in size or shrunk or
or contorted or something like that but
it's exactly the same damn structure
so as
as the brain was growing and the skull
was getting larger and women women's
bodies had to adapt to that well there
was parameters within which the body had
to work and it turns out that if you
make the hips any wider and you make the
hole in the middle of the many bigger
then the hips start to lose structural
integrity and the other thing that
starts to happen is the woman can't run
so there's this weird you imagine that
evolution takes place within this set of
constraints and so
what's happened is the baby gets born
way earlier the women's hips are wider
with a larger pelvic hole but not so
wide they can't run and not so wide
they're not strong and the baby's head
is collapsible roughly because the bones
aren't completely
fused at birth and so generally
especially if it's a larger baby if it's
born when it when it emerges just after
birth its head is quite compressed
cone-shaped even so and that's hard on
the baby but it's not nearly as hard on
the baby or the mother as not being born
at all
so anyways
babies are born pretty premature and you
know that puts a tremendous burden on
human parents because of course the
child is
you know can't even walk for the first
year whereas
you take a deer when a deer is born or
an animal like that you know it's
three minutes later it's wobbling around
on its feet and then it's running away
from lions the next morning it's like
that's that's not us you think why not
it's well we're born very very premature
and very very um vulnerable and you know
it's a major load on the on the parents
anyways
one question piaget was interested in is
well what exactly is a baby born with
and he thought well they're born with a
couple of things one is here's three
things in a sense you might think
they're born with a couple of reflexes
and what you might think of a as a
reflex is that it's a built-in module of
sensory motor
capability
and maybe it it and
you know maybe there's a motivational
element to it as well so i would say
it's a built-in sub-personality that's a
very narrow sub-personality has a very
narrow task and so one thing's one thing
babies can do is root so if you touch
them on the side of their cheek then
they root and basically what that means
is that they use their mouth and their
head to search for something to latch
onto with their mouth and that would
generally be a nipple so they come
pre-wired to be able to use their mouth
and their tongue and certain muscles of
their head in order to figure out how to
feed and that's actually a very
complicated behavior and so one of the
things you see with babies is that
their mouth and their tongue
is all quite wired up already so if
you're looking at a newborn baby the
intelligent part of the baby in some
sense like the part that's already there
is very much oriented towards its mouth
and its tongue and that's sort of like
freud's idea of an oral stage in some
sense although you know you could debate
that but that's partly why freud thought
that way he knew that babies were very
mouth-oriented
once they can start using their hands
and they can pick up objects what do
they do with objects
they put them in their mouth right why
well because that's what babies do
partly but that's not the only reason is
like
if you look at them
okay so back in the
50s 40s
maybe even earlier than that there was a
neurosurgeon named wilder penfield who
worked at the montreal neurological
institute and he was one of the people
who first did um
surgery for example for epilepsy so if
you have epilepsy what happens is
generally you kind of have a short
circuit there's a malfunctioning set of
neurons usually in the hippocampus and
they produce like a positive feedback
electrical circuit and it's like a
little electrical storm and it'll start
in damaged tissue and then spread across
the whole brain
and one of the things the early
neurosurgeons were doing was dividing
the brain in two to stop the hemisphere
that had the damage from being able to
spread pathological electric electricity
across the entire brain now when you're
doing brain surgery you don't want to
take out anything that isn't absolutely
necessary and so one of the things the
brain surgeons do and still do did and
still do is that they do brain surgery
when you're conscious
which is quite a horrifying thought
really because you know your head is
stuck in this little machine that
doesn't let it move and then they're
poking around in your brain and you have
to tell them what's going on while
you're doing it and if you stop being
able to respond then i presume they
assume that they've made a mistake and
you know tough luck for you but anyways
penfield was interested not only in
you know conducting his surgery properly
but also in mapping out the brain to
figure out well what parts of it could
you use and
you know what do you have to keep and
what parts can you maybe get rid of and
part of that was because there was an
idea for a long time among neurologists
called equal potentiality which meant
that
the the cortex was an undifferentiated
mass of tissue and you could take out
parts of it without really much loss of
function at all
um
which that turned out not to be exactly
right although it wasn't as stupid as an
idea as it might seem because the cortex
is less differentiated than other parts
of the brain but it turns out that if
you take out parts of it like the
prefrontal cortex the damage that it
does is not immediately evident but if
you watch the person for any length of
time well usually their lives fall apart
if their prefrontal cortex has been
damaged enough
anyway so penfield was trying to figure
out what the brain does and so he was
using electrodes to touch the surface
and what he found
if you imagine that this is the frontal
part of your brain here and it's called
that because it's at the front right and
so
there's a the back part of it has to do
more with sensory uh processing and then
there's a fissure down the middle and on
the front side of the fissure there's an
area that's roughly triangle shaped on
the back of the fissure there's another
area that's roughly triangle shaped and
the front part if you touch it with a
with an electrode like of the right
current obviously then people will
report feeling something on different
parts of their body and then if you
touch the part that's behind the fissure
so roughly about here it's so
then they'll they'll
be inclined to move or feel the impulse
to move and so what what
pinfield did was draw a little map of
what parts of the brain were connected
to what sensory sensations in the body
and what parts of the brain were
connected to what motor sensations and
he he built this thing called a
homunculus it's a little it's a little
picture and the picture is of this
creature that's laid out on the cortex
it's sort of like a dismembered body in
some sense and the size of each part
corresponds to the amount of tissue
that's devoted to processing that brain
or that bodily area and what you see is
very very interesting because if you
look there's a sensory homunculus that's
how your body looks to your brain from a
sensory perspective and there's a motor
homunculus which is how your body looks
to your brain from the perspective of
being able to operate it what you see
for example is with both the sensory and
the motor cortex the hand
is as big as the whole body and the
thumb is as big as the rest of the hand
and then the mouth and the tongue are
also that big and so is the face so
you've got this little itty-bitty body
because what are you what are you going
to do with your back you know you you
can't pick up anything with your back
and you're also not very good really
your your sensory perception on your
back is not very high resolution so if i
had one of you stand up and i put three
fingers on your back this far apart and
i said how many fingers were there you
wouldn't be able to tell you'd say one
probably but you can't tell even if you
space them out quite a bit if you push
simultaneously whereas on the surface of
the hand you can tell immediately
because this is a high resolution part
of your body and of course you know
you can really move your little
tentacley appendages here and they're
highly wired up to the brain as well and
very very sensitive but the reason i
told you all that because it's also
particularly true with the mouth and the
and the lips and the tongue and then
also the entire face that's because your
face is extraordinarily mobile and you
know you broadcast emotion with it and
so it's a it's a communication device of
the highest order and so it has to be
really wired up you have so much neural
control over your face that you can
actually teach yourself to fire single
neurons in the tissue underneath your
eye so which you certainly are not going
to be able to do with your back and then
of course well why would you anyways so
now
so what i'm telling you that in part so
that you get some more understanding of
how the child is wired up because that
mouth tongue
lip sort of arrangement that that that
the baby is born with is in that very
very powerful
learning
circuit and it's established quite
nicely right at birth and so then the
baby can start exploring the world
using parts of it that are already there
and a big chunk of that is the mouth so
and you know you know how this works
some of you
have recently had dental surgery of one
form or another or at least you can
remember when you had it maybe you had a
tooth fold or a filling or you had
braces put in or something so one of the
things you'll notice
if you lose a tooth
is that your damn tongue is in there
where the tooth was for the next six
months right fiddling around
and
you can do it consciously which you will
sometimes but even if you're not
attending to it your tongue will be in
there
checking out every tiny little crack and
crevice in the new area and what it's
doing is updating your map of the map of
your body because your mouth wants to
know what part of it's you and what part
of it isn't because first of all you're
not supposed to chew the parts that are
you and second of all if there's any
foreign body in the mouth obviously you
want to get that out of there for for
endless numbers of reasons
so
you can detect surface variation with
your lips and tongue with tremendous
accuracy and of course you know there's
all sorts of uses that people put that
ability to it's also one of the ways
that people uh test each other out for
sexual compatibility right because
that's all mouth and tongue work rough
not all of it obviously but
at least some reasonable proportion of
it and so that's also a part of
exploratory behavior so you're testing
for things like health with with kissing
and with smell
so
anyways it's a major part of you you
know and not only is it a part that you
that you explore the world with so that
you can figure out what to eat and what
not to eat which is a big problem for
omnivores right because we can eat damn
near anything and that's a complex
cognitive problem
but you also can use it as a tool for
exploring the contours of the world now
animals really do that with smell right
because your typical animal is a
smell-based creature whereas human
beings aren't really so much that
probably because we became upright and
for a bunch of other reasons but
smell is a tremendously powerful um
modality and it's pretty much fully
there at birth as well and you know
mothers report that they can distinguish
their baby by smell virtually you know a
day or two after they're born they know
the smell
and babies can certainly smell their
mothers and their fathers as well it
doesn't take very long at all
so anyways
the baby's got its mouth and so it can
start getting somewhere with that and
then it's also got basic reflexes you
know and now what a baby does in some
sense is
it's it's it starts developing from the
middle and the top
downward and outward
so the mouth and the nose are all wired
up the eyes start to get wired up fairly
quickly they're not much to begin with
because a baby will move its eyes
independently and it's not very good at
focusing although
its focal length
is actually its natural focal length is
pretty much exactly the distance from
breast to mother's eye which makes
perfect sense right because the baby
wants to be able to communicate
extraordinarily well to produce a bond
with the mother and that happens
most frequently with
during breastfeeding which is also
extremely good for the baby because the
baby gets touched and babies really
really really really need to be touched
if you don't touch them they die
so even if you feed them and shelter
them and all those sorts of things they
have to be touched and it's it's very
good for the baby's development so
anyways the baby starts out with
its its uh its ability to
explore with its mouth and its tongue
and its and its ability to smell and
then it starts to develop its eyes but
it does that in concert with developing
other parts of its body you know and so
the baby if you put the baby on its
stomach then it starts to exercise its
ability to lift up its head and so it
kind of gets that going and it starts to
learn how to use its arms and its legs
and
um so one thing you can do for a baby
for example to help it get going
so let's say the baby's in its crib
it's laying
face upward
okay you can give it a mobile
now if you go into a baby store and you
look at mobiles
what you'll see is maybe the top part is
like two coat hangers right it's like a
cross and then there's things hanging
from it
and the things will be i don't know
maybe they're cute who knows hello kitty
things or some damn thing like that
you know
and they're facing you
well that's a stupid mobile
because you aren't the person who's
supposed to be looking at the hello
kitty thinks the baby's supposed to be
looking at it so those should be facing
down and they never are they're always
facing sideways so when the baby looks
up all it sees is a bunch of horizontal
lines
but so let's assume that you're
reasonably bright and you get one that
the baby can see and then maybe it
should be black and white or at least
really really bright primary colors
because it's easier for a baby to detect
that black and white is really good
because baby's pretty good at detecting
edges and so that thing will move around
the baby will lay there and watch it you
know and
babies they i think they kind of look
like they're stoned on lsd all the time
you know and i actually think that's
technically correct because one of the
things that hallucinogens do is reduce
the um inhibiting power of memory on
perception and of course babies have no
inhibiting power of memory on perception
because they have no memory so they're
pretty much
you know completely overwhelmed by the
world all the time so they're laying
there watching this mobile and you know
you can shake it and maybe they'll have
a little reflex at that or or you can
interact with in some way and the baby
will start checking that out and it'll
watch it watch watch it it'll watch
partly so that it can get its eyes
organized
and it does that in concert to some
degree with its motor ability you know
because you might say
imagine you're cross-eyed a little bit
like a baby and you're looking at that
thing and there's two of them and you
might think well how do you know there's
not two of them
and the answer to that is well you have
to whack it with your hand as soon as
you whack it with your hand you're gonna
find out if it's one thing or two things
once you figure out whether that's one
arm or two arms you know and so the baby
is starting to to whack itself against
the world and watch the consequences to
help it start to build up its ability to
interact with the world and its ability
to model the world and so one of the
things you watch for example if you put
a baby
in a crib and it's got a mobile there
you want to kind of move the mobile down
so that it's close enough so that the
baby might be able to bump it because
babies if you if you don't swaddle them
they lay there and their hands and legs
sort of float in space like this and
it's because they're not really very
well connected to them and that's why a
baby will poke itself in the eye now and
then with his thumb and it's rather
amusing to watch in a kind of bleak
manner so a baby will lay there and
it'll poke itself it'll go like that
and what it's just discovered is that
there's some relationship between that
random movement and that sensation okay
now
okay so let's say it's laying there and
it's floating around in space and
it's fortunate enough so that its leg
comes into contact with an element of
the mobile well that'll make the mobile
do something
interesting and novel
and when the bait when the mobile does
something interesting and novel that
triggers a reflex in the baby and the
reflexes that the baby will orient
towards it and look
and so for piaget that was the
circuit that was the beginning of the
baby's ability to sort of start
bootstrapping it up in the world and he
thought what you needed was the ability
to move a little bit at least
so that'd be the reflex say or even
randomness and then you needed the
ability to refine that movement
so that you needed to be able to
practice it and you needed to be able to
improve with practice and you needed to
be able to imitate
and one of the things that piaget
thought which i think is so smart it's
so smart
is that what a lot of what babies did
was imitate themselves
so for example maybe they're they're
lying in bed and they're starting to get
some sense of of the connection between
of how their arms and legs work and so
they can maybe make start to make sort
of broad gestures and that's it but now
and then they they're lucky and they're
sort of flinging their arms around and
they hit the mobile and they get a
little
reflex out of that that's a startle and
an indication of interest and then
they'll sit there and practice how to
whack that thing with their hand and so
then what so what they're doing is
they kind of accidentally
produced a phenomena of interest
and they noted the consequence and then
what they do is try to reduplicate the
phenomena of interest so basically what
they're doing is
manifesting different patterns of
quasi-voluntarily
reflex
quasi-voluntary reflexive behavior and
then if that produces
something of note they'll practice
imitating it
so
when my daughter was about
months maybe not even that old
13 14 months maybe old enough to sit up
anyways and old enough to start to do
some things by herself
we bought her these books
they were disney books hardcover
cardboard books you know five pages long
or something each of the pages was quite
thick because it was made out of
cardboard and
they four of them would come in a little
box which is about four inches high and
about an inch and a half wide
and if you were really careful you could
take out the books
and then you could put all of them back
in it wasn't that easy
because
the first one wasn't too hard but they
got consi you know consistently more
difficult as you kept putting each of
them in because the parameters of the
exercise changed and she must have spent
i don't know 150 hours
dumping those out
picking them up
putting them in and you might say well
what was she doing
and you know you'd say well she was
putting books in a box that's not what
she was doing first of all they weren't
books to her and it wasn't a box because
she didn't know what a box was what she
was doing was practicing going like this
you know and matching the size of
something to uh to the size of something
else and that's very complicated and
maybe you know
so there's a
a jar of apple juice okay so you might
say well pick that up okay well you can
pick it up like this you can pick it up
like this you can pick it up like this
you can pick it up like this like
there's a lot of things to practice and
each of those movements is a different
sensory motor capacity that has an
incredibly wide range of potential
applications
so a child will sit there and fiddle
about with their hands and their arms
and the rest of their body for untold
hours because what they're doing is
building up these basic sensory motor
systems from the bottom up so that they
can you know so so they practice them in
one domain where there's some challenge
and then they're starting to build new
exploratory tools that they can go out
and practice on the rest of the world so
you know once you can grip uh let's say
once you can grip a mobile
and you can let go which is something
babies actually have a hard time doing
because they have a grip reflex and
they're quite strong when they're first
born if you put your fingers in their
hands you can lift them right off the
ground they'll cling to you and that's
probably old chimpanzee gripping
behavior because chimps grab to their
mother's fur and then they're like
carried around like that for about three
years now since you don't have much fur
it's kind of useless for the baby
although they're pretty good at getting
your hair and your glasses and your nose
and so
and you've got to get them to let go
so anyways they'll sit there and
practice all these little sub routines
and so you'll see this too if you have a
baby
you've got your baby in the high chair
maybe it's nine months old and you're
trying to
feed the baby which is often very uh
challenging because babies are very
curious and annoying and troublesome and
tough and ornery and exploratory and and
misbehaving and provocative and all
those things because they need that to
learn about the world and they'll
they'll do something like maybe they'll
eat and they'll
drop the spoon and a mess will go on the
floor
and they think wow gravity that's
interesting so then you'll give them
their spoon again and the first thing
they'll do is take their food and fling
it on the floor
and then they'll do that lots because
they're kind of interested in this whole
twisting the spoon and having things
fall on the floor phenomena and so it's
part of the reason why it's often hard
to feed babies is because even if
they're hungry you feed them three
things and then they're not starving and
then they're so hyper curious that
they're gonna you know try to do
something else so
but what they're doing is they're
they're continually
utilizing their basic reflexive behavior
and building
more and more complex structures up on
the basis of that and with each time
they do that it opens up a new toolbox
for them and they you know expand
outward and start to interact with the
world and so
that's one way also of understanding
where a baby's personality comes from
now this is complicated because
there are things about babies that are
sort of
their parameters of personality are
somewhat determined at birth
so i'll tell you how i i've
conceptualized this it's it's how you
might conceptualize the relationship
between nature and nurture
i don't know if this is a good metaphor
or not it's not the most elegant
metaphor in the world but it's worked
for me
so
imagine for example
that
a baby
at three months of age can be a calm
baby or a nervous baby now that is the
case we know that even right at birth
you could kind of figure out whether a
baby is a calm baby or a nervous baby
that's neuroticism that's the
fundamental dimension of negative
emotion
so you might say that
one baby's nervous behavior might have
this range and another baby's nervous
behavior might have this range and
another baby's nervous behavior might
have this range and most of the time
it's sort of in the middle of that range
and now and then it'll manifest
behaviors that are
associated with what's extreme for it so
even if you have a calm baby sometimes
it'll get upset and even if you have a
baby that's always upset sometimes it
will be calm
so then you might ask yourself well
to what degree
can you modulate the baby's
nervous behavior so let's say you want
to have more calm baby and so you're
going to do some things to make that
baby calm the question is how
much
transformation can you make and the
answer to that to some degree is it
depends on how much effort you make
so
changes that are close to the average of
the baby's natural curve of responses
are fairly easy to make so you can shift
the baby a little bit towards being more
calm without too much work
but if you want to shift it more towards
being calm then that's going to take
more work and if you're going to shift
it more to be calm that's going to take
more work and it's not linear
so what happens is at some point you
kind of reach a practical limit you're
not going to make your baby more calm
than you know maybe you could move it
one standard deviation or two standard
deviations from its its natural
resting place when it was first when it
first emerged as a creature but if
you're going to move it three to met
three standard deviations like from the
fifth percentile to the 95th percentile
you're going to be working up you're not
going to be doing anything else with the
baby so
you can sort of conceptualize the
relationship between nature and nurture
as a cost relationship
so for example iq is quite stable but
you can move iq but it's really
expensive
so there's a practical limit to it so
i think if you take twins that are
adopted out at birth
in order to get a 15 point difference in
iq between the twins by the time they
become adult one twin has to be at the
95th percentile for wealth in their
family and the other twin has to be at
the fifth percentile for wealth so
that's a massive difference right it's
huge and so it's such a big difference
you're not going to produce that with
any degree of ease in the real world but
so
environmental transformations of
biological parameters cost that's a very
useful way of thinking about it so
so anyways back to the baby
now
the baby is starting to organize itself
from the bottom up and so here's here's
kind of a way to think about how that
works
piaget pointed out that and this is
quite well known in the development
literature that
babies
that are younger than three
don't really play well with others
and
it's complicated because they can play
some things with others so for example
you can play peek-a-boo quite well with
a nine-month-old
you know so there's some sort of simple
games that
that babies can play with you
pretty much as soon as they get their
eyes focused
and
one of the funny things about babies
when they're very young even below nine
months is that they already have a sense
of humor which is something i've never
been able to figure out so they can play
little comical games with you
as soon as you're smart enough to figure
out what the baby's up to roughly
speaking because they they appreciate
humor
absurdly early and it's very difficult
to understand why look anyways it
doesn't matter
the piagetian idea was in some sense
that what the baby does to begin with is
first plays games with itself
so it's exploring you know and then it
produces some phenomena of interest and
then it replicates that until it masters
it and then you know it just keeps doing
that and it gets to be more and more and
more complex and then by the time it's
about three
it's complex enough so that all of its
little micro systems are
kind of integrated into one thing you
know so it's got a set of routines for
being hungry it's got a set of routines
for being anxious it's got a set of
routines for being exploratory it's got
a set of routines for seeking um
attention from its parent and so on and
then it's starting to build some
overarching unity among all of those
micro
processes so that
it can segue smoothly between them
and you can really see this starting to
happen at two because you know you've
heard of the terrible twos and what
happens in the terrible twos is that the
child's still fairly
unintegrated and so they'll go they're
quite a riot to be around because
they're staggeringly emotional you know
they'll go from
giddy beyond belief to crying
outrageously to so angry that if you
ever saw an adult that angry you would
immediately run away and call the police
and they can do that like in 15 minutes
they just cycle through these things
very very rapidly so and and weirdly
enough
adults will notice behaviors they'll see
behaviors in children that would be
absolutely outrageous in adults and they
don't even really
it doesn't phase them at all it shows
you how well adapted we are to children
because you know a child who's having a
tantrum if the child's good at it you
know they'll fling themselves onto the
floor which you rarely see an adult do
and then they'll pound and kick and
scream and then if they're really good
at it and some of them get really
amazingly good at it they'll hold their
breath until they turn blue and pass out
it's like try that one night when you're
you know when you don't have anything to
do and you're and the power's off you
know just see if you can kick and scream
on the floor for a while and then hold
your breath till you turn blue and pass
out you can't
and that just shows you how you know
committed to the tantrum a child can be
so
it's easy to stop that sort of behavior
by the way um so if your child throws a
tantrum it's at home
just go away
and then eventually the child will turn
blue and you know pass out then they'll
come too and there isn't anyone there
and that's not really an exciting
outcome so if you do that two or three
times the child usually figures out that
it's really not worth the hassle if you
want the child to continue
wait until they turn blue and pass out
and then really freak out especially if
you can do that randomly a few times man
you'll get that child just having
tantrums turning blue and passing out
pretty much everywhere
yeah so don't don't do that that's a bad
idea so
all right
now so the piagetian idea in some sense
is the child builds up these little
reflexes and these little we'll call
them sub personalities because it's a
better way of thinking about it and it
starts to build them around
modern
psychologists would think more that it
starts to build them around motivational
systems piaget wouldn't necessarily said
that but
and then
at some point the child starts to enter
the social world
now
it's simple in some ways to think of the
child before three as not social and
then the child
after three is social but it's not
really accurate right because if you
think about it
the child is being social right from the
beginning of its development because
first of all it has to figure out for
example how to feed even if it's not
being breastfed it has to figure out how
to participate
in a playful and social manner around
feeding and that's particularly the case
if the child has to breastfeed because
breastfeeding is very complex
process
first of all you have to get the mother
to cooperate and you can't bite her for
example and so there's all sorts of
rules about breastfeeding that the baby
has to follow and so the baby's actually
entering into fairly complex social
relationships and games
right from the beginning and that's
especially true if it also has siblings
because if you know if you have a baby
and maybe you have a two-year-old the
two-year-old and the baby are playing
right off the bat and their
two-year-olds are amazingly good at
playing with newborns
it's quite staggering to watch them and
so if you're thinking about having
children i also recommend not just
having one because one child is way more
work than three
because you have to amuse one child all
the time whereas if you have three you
can ignore them completely and they'll
just raise each other
it's actually much better for the
children you know as long as you're
there not to make sure they don't light
each other on fire and that sort of
thing which is you're basically your job
so okay but we'll act for the time being
as if the child
isn't social till three because that's a
simplification but it's a useful one so
piaget was also extremely interested in
how the child became social
and
i think apart from
his ideas about
you know the the the self-generation of
the baby from the bottom upward
using its own reflexes and its own
capacity to explore the other thing that
piaget was extraordinarily good at
laying out and and remarkable at
discovering was
the role of games
and so
piaget
was the
first psychologist
i would say
who
discovered just how important it is to
have kids play
now the problem with play is that it's
fun and so utilitarian people especially
ones that are really conscientious have
this idea that if it's fun it can't
really be good for you and so
because of that
the role of play in children was not and
still isn't appreciated in the full
dimensions of its importance so for
example
you know we take little kids that are in
grade one they're like six you know and
what do we do with them we put them in
chairs like the ones you're in you've
been in that damn chair for like 16
years you know it's like we take those
little
characters and we put them in chairs and
we expect them to sit there and listen
to adults for six hours a day well it's
it's so idiotic that it it's beyond
comprehension it's no wonder the little
blighters are hyperactive you know that
just means they're alive
they should be taken out into the
schoolyard and supervised while playing
until they're completely exhausted then
they should have a little nap then maybe
you could teach them something for a
while
but
stopping them from playing and or or not
facilitating play among them is
absolutely crazy because that's exactly
how children come to become social in
the world and the reason for that is
that
the games children play are analogs of
the activities that adults engage in
well it's not that hard to figure it out
figure that out if you think about it i
mean think about playing monopoly you're
a teenager you play monopoly how many
people have played monopoly
right everybody's played monopoly well
what are you doing it's like evil
capitalist pig game right
so and you know if you're going to grow
up to be an evil capitalist pig then you
can get a good practice good good
practice going by playing monopoly and
you can you can become part of the one
percent which is what you have to do to
win right you need to have all the
hotels and so no one else has any hotels
and you know you play that and it's fun
it's fun
so
it's an analog of real life
now it's an analog of real life in many
ways because most of the things that you
do with other people involve adhering to
a set of shared rules
and most of the things that you do with
other people involve
cooperating and competing with them
so if you're playing monopoly are you
cooperating or competing
how many people think competing
okay how many people think cooperating
okay
you're cooperating
are you playing the same rules
are you playing by the same rules well
yes unless you're cheating if you're
cheating you're not playing monopoly
right you're cheating that's a different
game
so to play monopoly you have to
cooperate because you have to all agree
to sit in the same place you have to
agree not to steal the money you have to
agree that the stupid rules which are
completely arbitrary are the ones that
are going to govern your life for the
next you know two hours you have to
agree to try you have to agree to try to
have fun you have to agree to try to be
like a good player which means you don't
get all snively and whiny when someone
when you land on someone's boardwalk and
they completely bankrupt you you know
so you're cooperating like mad
and another thing piaget pointed out
which is absolutely lovely is that
you can't have a game without
cooperation and competition at the same
time
so there's no such thing as cooperative
games
you have to have
for it to be a game it has to be
competition within cooperation or it can
be cooperation within competition within
cooperation you know these things are
very complexly nested so if you're
playing hockey for example
is is hockey an aggressive game or a or
a cooperative game
well
you have to play by the rules so both
teams agree to that you're on the ice at
the same time you don't bring a
basketball you don't bring a chess game
you're there to play hockey
are you cooperating or competing with
your teammates
well both right you're cooperating with
them because you want everyone to win
plus you want everybody to get better at
playing across time but you're competing
with them because maybe you could be the
star of the game
and everybody's happy about that and
then with the other team well are you
cooperating or competing with them well
as long as you're playing by the rules
you're cooperating but there's obviously
an element of competition now almost
every human activity has
those elements there's a body of rules
underneath it or if they're not rules
they're at least social conventions
right they're things that people
understand are allowed and not allowed
and then there's a competitive and a
cooperative element all right so
that's what children start to become
particularly exposed to when they're
about three
how piaget pointed out that there were
in some sense two classes of children's
games there was the
games that have a really clearly defined
aim
and that'd be the goal
and that'd be like you know in the
little circles that we were talking
about that's where you're trying to go
now the thing about it being a game is
that all of you have to be trying to go
there at the same time
and so what piaget realized was that
just as the child is trying to integrate
all their little micro games inside them
into some sort of unified thing which
would be the child a stable personality
across time and capable of weathering
the storms of life
when a group of children get together
they build another one of those routines
but it includes all of them and so the
kids might say well let's play
um hide and go seek that's a good one
and everyone knows the rules to hide and
go seek and you can win or lose it hide
and go seek but what you're trying to do
is you have to bring your sub
personalities
all the way up to their integrated state
underneath a meta structure
that's organized by the collection of
children so the child would say well do
you want to play hide and go seek and
you're supposed to say you're either
supposed to say yes or
perhaps pause it another game you're not
supposed to freak out or get angry or
say that that's a stupid game or run
back to your mom because then you're not
going to be very popular and you're not
going to get to play and if you don't
get to play well then you're you're
ruined because if you don't learn how to
play with others between two and four
you never learn and then you're some
poor outcast and maybe you end up in
jail or at least you end up like
isolated and
and awkward and and
poorly socially integrated and
that's not good because if you don't get
into the kids games at three all of them
start moving ahead and you don't and the
farther they've moved ahead past you the
less likely it is that they're going to
play with you so one of the things
that's really worth thinking about
if you're going to have kids is you have
a job as a parent and your job as a
parent is to make your child
socially acceptable especially to other
children by the time they're three
and if you don't do that well
that's not very good you'll pay for it
and so were you a child and you know
there's been lots of long-term
follow-ups on this sort of thing and it
seems pretty evident that if the kid
isn't socialized by four
then
good luck
there's no evidence at all from the
developmental literature which is quite
a dismal literature that you can fix
that
so anyways all right so the children all
get together and they say well here's
what we're going to do
and everyone says yes and so they orient
their personalities towards that goal
and then they interact in a cooperative
and competitive way
in pursuing the goal and that's a game
and what they're doing is practicing
being social human beings
and so and they do that with all sorts
of different games and then you might
say well
here's something really worth thinking
about
what does it mean to be a functional
human being
it to me it means to be the sort of
that can be a good player across
multiple games
so you might think for example
you tell your kid
i'll tell you a story about a hockey
game that i saw once
hockey parents say 10 percent of them
should just be jailed as soon as they
enter the arena
so when my kid played
um
i don't know what you call it
a level high level hockey for a while
when he was a kid anyways he was a good
he was a good hockey player
but it was really unbearable so we
didn't do it for very long for a variety
of reasons but anyways
on his way to
learning how to play hockey
he was in one of these uh
local
leagues we have an arena just around the
corner fortunately enough and he wasn't
the best player on the team
there was a another kid on the team who
was who was better i would say
and uh
he uh
he was in a championship game at one
point he hadn't been in very many
championship games because his teams
often weren't very good but anyways it
was the local championship and
we went and watched and
it was a really fun game you know like
it was really close i think it i think
it was three three till the final 15 or
20 seconds and then some kid from the
other team
scored a really good goal you know it
was wasn't one of those things where
they accidentally kicked the puck into
the net or something it was a really
nice play and so it was a tight game the
teams were well matched the local league
had made sure like they'd set up teams
together and then if one team kept
winning too consistently or one losing
too consistently they'd sort of revamp
the team so they were roughly equal
which i really liked because you know
all the kids got a reasonably equal shot
at it and everybody got to develop so
anyways we were watching that it was
pretty fun
and uh
the the star kid he was skating around
out there and
the game ended and he went off the ice
and he smashed his hockey stick onto the
cement because he was all irritated and
you know which was pretty pathetic and
then his father came running up to him
and said oh you got robbed it was really
terrible um you know the reffing was bad
and you played very well and you should
have won the game and he didn't say you
know stop being a little rat and
smashing your hockey stick onto the
cement like you're three which is what
he should have said he
he
basically rewarded his child for
narcissistic
uh immature misbehavior so it was pretty
pathetic it was child abuse as far as
i'm concerned sort of of the psyche
really man that's stupid what are you
gonna do you're gonna train your child
to be a narcissist it's like that course
that's child abuse it's moronic of
course it was due to his own foolishness
but i don't know if that's criminal
right but it was really pathetic so but
no but think about this now for a minute
so you might think well what did that
kid do wrong it's like
well he wanted to win so that's okay
you should want to win if you're playing
a game i mean you're not any fun if
you're playing a game and you're not
trying to win and there's nothing more
miserable than playing a game with
someone and at the end they say well you
won because i wasn't really trying it's
like you know you're not going to play
with them again if they do that and
that's kind of interesting because it
means they've done something wrong
you know and even a kid can figure that
out and so you might tell your kid
be a good sport
and it doesn't matter whether you win or
not it matters how you play the game now
what the hell kid doesn't know how to
what to make of that and you hardly even
believe it right you think yeah it does
matter if you win so i don't know what
this means but you'll tell the child
that and so then you might think well
what does it mean
to be a good sport and and that and that
how you play the game is more important
than whether you win or lose okay so
think about it this way
what's your goal
well you might say to win the hockey
game
but that implies you're only going to
play one hockey game what if you can
play a hundred hockey games
and then forget about that what if
you're going to play 100 hockey games
and 200 basketball games and 50 chess
games and you're gonna have a bunch of
jobs and you're gonna have a bunch of
friends and you can have a bunch of
relationships and all of those have a
game-like structure
and let's say that you're a real son of
a when you play hockey and so no
one ever invites you to do any of those
other things it's like well you win the
game but you lose the metagame
and the metagame is the game that's made
up of all the games you're ever going to
play
and what apparent means when they say
doesn't matter whether you win or lose
it matters how you play the game is that
the metagame is more important than the
game and you should learn how to play
games so that whether or not you win or
lose people really want to play with you
because if they want to play with you
man you're set right so
here's here's a cool game so okay
you two are going to play this game are
you ready okay so here's the deal
i'm going to give you 20 dollars
you have to give some of that to him
you want to get to offer once if he
rejects it neither of you get anything
okay how much are you gonna give him
ten would you take that okay
okay you would why
i mean
like first is better than nothing yes
it's fair right yeah yeah so here's this
experiment has been done all over the
world
and so basically what they find is that
people pretty much offer 50 50. now
here's something cool let's say you go
play this game and use 20 bucks and
you're playing it with really poor
people
and so you you set the game up so you
say look
offer him two bucks he's poor
he'll take it so you offer him two bucks
what does he do
he tells you to screw off
right and he's more likely to do that if
he's poorer
so that's pretty interesting because
like a classical economist would say
look what you should have done was offer
them a dollar it's like you get 19. you
get 19. he gets a dollar he's gonna take
the damn dollar because it's better than
nothing but that isn't what people are
like it's like you give them a dollar
and you get 19 they want to punch you
right they're not going to take that and
that's because they don't want to play
the game that way
they want to play the game so that it's
fair across multiple games
now you might say let's say you're
playing that in front of a whole bunch
of people like we were now
and let's say all these people are going
to be able to invite you to play the
same game and so maybe you're going to
be able to make 400 in the next hour
so then you might say well what should i
do if i wanted everybody to invite me to
play this game as much as possible then
how much would you offer
15 exactly that's cool so that means
actually you lost the game the one game
right because you only get 15 five and
he gets 15 but like everyone's thinking
hey i'm going to play this game with her
well that's that's what it means when
you tell someone to play the game
properly
you say act as if while you're playing a
specific game that there's a higher
order moral principle that has to do
with the total number of games that
you're going to play across your entire
life and play that game properly
yeah well that's the evolution of higher
moral thinking in part from a piagetian
perspective it's bloody brilliant
so
all right we'll see you
tuesday
you